argentina la segunda seleccion del sur
americano cual consejo sobre cual tuyo
qatar de negocio de impacto cero contra
el wan chino para la ruta de chile de
permite la clasificación consecuencias a
cuatro con la esfera terminada en e
sas eliminacion que en el mes atras es
hijo de [ __ ] pelean eso después
que emoción ha marcado a paul a
colapso de otamendi con tra rafinha
seria del final de la primera parte de
quien no fue visto doctor el bar
hablar sobre el sabor del té te del
el criador de brasil tiene que amar
el fácil empezó con el
clasificación nos aseguró el abacá
danimar que uno entra herido y en el
resto de la escoria bolivia gargantas oa
uruguay peru venezuela como es masculino
para dios y tela con entre ecuador y yen
en casa y colombia e impacto en embarque
ya anti paraguay brasil termino
ultima flecha de la eliminatoria asi eno
llama años y no mas balance de
mesa con te 35.29 en argentina ecuador
tanto pienza como 30 con 23 puntos a
comienza en ai tenemo sassi en co
la selección separa la escuela vale la pena
cue son colombia peru chile uruguay
bolivia recordamos al primer equipo un
hombre directamente al mondial mientras sube
quien entenderá que la cuota por una plaza
de rap y chaquetas masiamo senado filas
un elenco de eliminatorias al sur americano y al
mocoso eliminacion sudamericana
pampararo una macro reseña de dicho lo
país en el que fui metí qatar donde
el 20 o
tamaño borghetto mantenemos a tres si
selección desclasificación mundos vespertinos a las 22h
obviamente son qatar que tiene la aficion
en brasilia americana cientos
demas y sus ojos de europa de moises
bélgica croacia dinamarca tierra
franzi alemania país ocio serbia e
españa la suisa la thienesi banal repesa
que continente politico italia macedonia
norte de polonia portugal rusia e
escocia suez y türkiye ucrania gales
austria en república checa solo
German vanackere el ascenso al mundial
en el hombre en el continente africano
siempre que ya esté definida como la última vuelta
de la clasificación a quien aparece
Camerún que los años que dan túnel a
equipo de la republica democratica del congo
costumbres mali marruecos y senegal b e spies
en total llámalo cierto cinco plaza
directo